الطريقة التي تظهر بها زاوية هذه الطاقة
هي حقًا تضرب
ماليبو على وجه التحديد بشدة
، من المثير للاهتمام تمامًا كيف يكون
مستوى طاقة الجميع مثل راكب الأمواج عندما يظهر
الأقنان فقط طاقتك
فقط لأنني أعتقد أنك نوع من
تعد نفسك لمقدار
الطاقة الذي ستستغرقه لتكون قادرًا على
أن تكون في هذه الظروف ، لذا فأنت
تعلم أعني أننا نعيش لهذا الأمر
كما لو أننا ننتظر حياتنا حتى تحدث هذه الأشياء
.  لقد كنت أعيش في ماليبو لمدة
20 عامًا ولا أعتقد أنني رأيت
شيئًا مثل هذا تمامًا لقد رأيت
بعض الانتفاخات الكبيرة هنا ، وهناك
مجموعة متسقة من حين لآخر ،
هناك مجموعة أكبر
بشكل استثنائي شائعة جدًا  في هذا الوقت من
العام ، ستعرف أنك قد
تكون هناك موجة يبلغ ارتفاعها 8 أقدام و 10 أقدام ،
ثم فجأة هناك موجة 15 أو 20 قدمًا
، وهذه الموجات تأتي كثيرًا بشكل
أقل ، لذا يكون لديك هذا
الحجم الواحد و  ثم إذا كنت لا
تشاهد حقا سوف  تسلل إليك ، لذا
نحاول دائمًا إبقاء أعيننا
في الأفق